DENNIS KHVOSTIONOV: My
name is Dennis Khvostionov.
I'm the Chief Technology
Officer of DGLogik.
And the presentation, as you
can see, is titled Dart for IOT.
I think everyone
here at this point
already knows what Dart is.
So I'm going to try
to tell you about IOT
and how we are applying Dart
to solve really complicated use
cases.
First, a little
definition from wiki.
So the internet of
things is defined
as uniquely
identifiable objects and
their virtual representations.
Now, when these things and
objects all swarm and connect,
now we start to get
the interesting use
cases that can be achieved.
But IOT as it stands
really talks about things.
So if we look at things, we
actually have a few over here
that we're going
to be looking at.
These things are devices
that are typically
outputing telemetry data.
And by the standard
definition of IOT,
if we take these devices and we
connect them to the internet,
they become an internet enabled
thing-- hence, the acronym IOT.
What I'm actually here
to talk about is IOE.
IOE is something that actually
now takes things, services,
people, processes, and data and
these other devices and things
and connects them together
to actually provide
even more value.
So when you look at
cities of the future
and all the management
systems that
are going to be running these
cities or islands-- as we'll
show you-- this is what IOE
is-- internet of everything.
Next, I'd like to show
you the little things.
So you can see here we
have a little Intel Edison.
We have a little robot
that's connected.
And we have an interface that
was developed to control them.
So what I'll be
talking about today
is all the technology that
we built utilizing Dart.
As you can see here, this
is actually an application
that was fully built in Dart.
It's actually
deployed as Dart2JS.
You can see all the things
that we brought today
and how they're
all interconnected.
For example, I can use my phone
as a sensory input device,
and you can start to see
that I'm rotating the phone
and this is all in real time.
You can see the little
Philips Hue light bulbs
that I have right in front
of me changing their colors.
Of course, we can do the
same thing with the robot.
But the robot can talk.
We have an Android
phone here that's
running a piece of software.
And we can make this
Android phone talk.
Sometimes.
So all of these things
that are connected together
is what we are going
to be talking about.
So I'm going to switch
back to the presentation
to introduce a little
bit about the technology
and how it was developed.
So let me start with
what our company.
So the company is called DGLogik
and we were founded in 2007.
We set out to create technology
to help build applications
without necessarily
being a developer.
So we're utilizing Dart to
build these applications
as I will later show you.
Our core business is software
for the internet of everything.
Today, we're announcing
an open source effort
for application enablement
of internet of everything
called distributed
services architecture.
And another piece of software
that we developed-- this
is our commercial product--
this is called DGLux.
And this is what is used to
develop applications that
are linking all of these
real time sensors and pieces
of information together.
The products and
everything I'm going
to show be showing
you today, these
are not proof of concepts.
The demo was put together just
to illustrate the concepts that
are already being deployed
and already used commercially
by our customers.
And we have a very
strong presence
in building automation
and business
intelligence and visualization.
So all this technology has
been vetted with our customers.
Now, these deployments
are global.
We've utilized Dart to create
a technology and a solution,
and we're able to train
other companies how
to use a solution.
And these companies are
implementing the use cases
that they see fit.
For example, there
are container ships
that are being monitored
by the software I'll
be showing you-- all
the rope tensioners
and LIDARs, et cetera.
And you can see the
different types of use cases
that have been
developed and where
the companies that
implemented those use cases
are located worldwide-- these
are all our distributors.
Now to the fun stuff.
This is DGLux.
It stands for the
DGLogik User Experience.
You'll notice it's a
version of DGLux 5.
It's because it's HTML5.
The prior version was DGLux 2.5.
So we kind of made
a little jump.
That version was made in Flex.
We used to love Flex.
As a technology,
the productivity
that it allowed our
developers to have,
and when we started
investigating moving to HTML5,
we looked at many
different frameworks
because that's what
they are for JavaScript.
And one framework would
do something for us,
but there will
always be some gaps.
And luckily, we found Dart.
It was definitely pre-release.
But we deployed as
a DGLux 5 release
when Dart was still 0.8 version.
So we didn't even wait
for Dart to become 1.0
to deploy the first commercial
deployment of DGLux 5.
What is this application?
So you can see in
the screenshot,
it looks like a
design environment.
Well, DGLux, it's a
what you see is what you
get builder for applications.
You do not need
to be a developer
to build any kind of
HTML5 whether it's
application or a dashboard or
some sort of interactive form.
Really anything that you
can see yourself building
that is hosted in
the web browser that
will run on mobile
as well as desktop
you can build this in DGLux.
The little screen shot
you see in the bottom,
this is data flow.
Because you can build
an application just
to be a visual application.
You need to create custom logic.
If I click here but
some sort of drop
down has a value [INAUDIBLE],
something else needs to happen.
So this is the data
full logic editor
that is built into DGLux 5.
Of course, there's a
block for scripting.
And you can use script to
make custom functionality.
But most the time
we find we can just
use the blocks from
the library to achieve
any type of logic we want.
This application itself
is more than 200,000 lines
of Dart code.
One of the things that we love
the most-- well, not the most--
but one of the things
we love about Dart
is the rapid testing,
rapid debugging.
We're able to press play
and we can see the results
immediately-- right away.
This application has been
in production since 2013.
There's thousands of
deployments of this globally.
And the bugs that we see that
are coming back to us-- well,
there are bugs.
You can't really blame
Dart for anything,
for any of those bugs.
And the way it's
deployed is Dart 2JS
has never really seen
any issues with that.
In the beginning, before
actually using Dart,
we thought that we
would develop in Dart
and we would compile
to JavaScript
and we would have some sort
of [? computability ?] things.
But we've been saved from that.
So that's not an
issue for us at all.
Next, I'd like to
show you some projects
that were actually
created using this tool
and that are actually live.
This is actually the data
center, as you can see.
And this is made for an iPad.
The heat map is
showing 700 data points
that are all rapidly updating--
showing all the different rack
temperatures inside.
And then you can
see on the right
a little bit of analytics.
This is a smart island.
DGLux was used to create
the interface for it.
It's solar power, wind turbines.
This is a social media center.
So if you go to
conferences, you might
see certain kiosks
that are showing you
real-time tweets
and all the event
information and statistics.
DGLux is also used
to power these.
And again, these actually run
on embedded webkit devices.
Actually, these
screens are powered
by devices that are
using, as I mentioned,
an embedded version
of webkit from QT.
So it's a QT web kit.
And of course, smart cities
utilizing other Google products
such as Google Maps allow
a really nice interaction
and show a list of views of
where all the data is located,
as well as analyzing
all that information.
Now, I'd like to
introduce you to DSA.
I think the logo does it justice
to explain really what it does.
So DSA solves IOT.
And what do I mean
by solving IOT?
When I said in the beginning
when IOT is considered,
you're looking at a
device and this device
is connected to the
cloud or the internet.
In my mind, that this
is not necessarily
what IOT and IOE is because in
real production deployments,
you always have
other networks-- they
need to connect
to other networks.
So it's never a
direct connection
from a device to the cloud.
Even if you look at
your home, you're
going to have all
your home devices.
Right now, it is transparent.
So most of the connected
devices for your home,
you plug in your router and
they have a direct connection
to the internet and they're
talking to the cloud.
However, in the future,
what we're going to see
is a hub in your house.
All the devices are connected
to some sort of hub.
This hub might be connected
to other hubs that
are in your neighborhood.
Because when everything is
going to be connected together--
which is what internet
of things and everything
implies-- that means all of
these devices in your home
and let's say the light pole
outside as well as the traffic
signal because it knows that
you just left your house,
all of these things
will be connected.
And in order to
properly connect them,
it will be connected as
networks of networks together.
DSA is an open source platform.
DSA was really created for us--
that's a little selfish reason
initially when we started it.
Because DGLux, the visualization
technologies that I showed you
that is used to
build applications,
we will sell more of it when
there is more data available.
That is a reason why we
made DSA open source is
that we want the
community, we want
everyone to build
applications that
are sitting a little higher
level that are utilizing all
the connectivity and all of
the device profiles and device
attractions that DSA provides.
So you can think of DSA
as taking all of the code
libraries that are available
for the interoperability
of the different devices
and joining them together
into something that is
normalized-- something that
can work together.
So your Philips Hue knows
about maybe a Nest thermostat.
To get into a little more detail
and how Dart was utilized,
here's a logical diagram.
As you can see, we're going
to start top to bottom.
So whenever we talk about
a device and the devices
that I have here, you're
always going to start, well,
how do I talk to the
end device specifically?
Some devices will implement
an HTP based protocol.
Bluetooth LE or Bluetooth 4.0.
At the end of the
day, you can't ever
predict really
what your end point
and what your edge
device will use.
In industrial
automation, we're still
using RS485
communications, which is
really slow serial protocols.
So what we've done is
we've abstracted this logic
and we're trying to think
about it as a black box.
And we call them DS links.
So if I create an
implementation for Philips Hue,
I'm going to create a
Phillips Hue DS link.
And that's what you can see
here that's running here.
All of these links are
connecting to a broker.
So you can have
multiple links that are
going to connect to a broker.
And what that's going
to do is that's going
to allow the links that
to connected to the broker
with proper permissions to talk
to other links that are also
connected to the broker.
So you're now able to have
devices that are communicating
devices or things or
services-- communicating
to each other-- through the
central fuel broker node.
Because we're normalizing the
proprietary protocol of Philips
Hue or the MiP robot or
whatever else is connected,
we're normalizing that
right on the DS link.
We can always treat a
DS link as a black box.
And all of the data
that's coming out of it
is called mode API.
So brokers themselves can also
be connected to other brokers.
So now you can see how we can
form this graph of networks
and graphs of connected things.
And if you want to build an
application, which I really
hope that you do because the
whole point of open source
in DSA is to drive the community
effort so that everyone can
contribute new services, new
functionality, new protocol
converters to this effort.
The types of links
that are possible
include-- as you can see here,
of course-- device drivers.
But also things like historians.
So once all of this
activity is happening,
maybe I want to start logging
this data into a Hadoop
database.
So that's also a link because it
has access to everything that's
going on.
A broker, you can
just plug this link in
and it'll start
logging all the data
and exposing it to
whoever now wants
to get this historical data.
If you would like to do
analytics or machine learning,
there's really
great projects out
there look Apache
Spark and the machine
learning library
that's included there.
So these are the types of
links so you can create.
DGLux itself, the
user experience
I showed you, that
is also a link.
So that is also
connected to a broker.
And that just gets all the
data that is on the broker
and you're able to browse
it, as I'll show you.
The way DSA is created is
the reference implementation
is 100% ours.
Underneath it's using
WebSockets with HTTP
fallback for communications.
We've seen really
good performance.
I don't know if you saw that
when I was spinning my phone,
it was really, really quick.
And that actually
transfers all the way
down to the edge of
the network as well.
We also have currently
ported the Dart SDK
into Java and Node.js.
So even in this demo, we
have Node.js DS links,
there's Java DS
links, but they're all
connected into the broker.
So now we have this language
interoperability happening.
On our roadmap-- and we really
hope community could help us
with this-- is to
just make SDKs for DSA
in all the various languages.
Because what we believe is
that there is an existing
software out there already
created in some language
that we want to utilize as part
of this internet of everything.
So if there is a SDK that
is in that native language,
it's much easier to plug
this connected functionality
into that existing
piece of software.
Now let's look at this demo
again that I was showing you.
And let's look at it
in a little more detail
from the point of view of what
I just to explained to you.
Sorry about that.
That's coming a little later.
So we have the Intel Edison that
I showed a picture of earlier.
And this is a very
small embedded device.
And I'll actually pause
for a couple of seconds
while I talk about it and show
it to you on the big screen.
So all the connected
devices are actually
running from this
little Intel Edison.
It is running the Dart DM--
so it's running the broker.
It's running a Dart
web server, which
is where are you see
DGLux being served from.
It's also hosting DGLux, so
it's hosting all the graphics.
It's hosting the
development environment,
so you can actually build
and visualize everything.
It's also running a little
node to show interoperability
with other languages--
for communicating,
let's say, with the
Philips Hue light.
And this Intel
Edison is actually
connected to another gateway.
And you can see here in
my interactive diagram
this little Dell
Industrial Gateway.
Now, this Dell
Industrial Gateway,
that's running the
Dart broker as well--
and if you're curious about
the operating systems,
the Edison is running ioctl
Linux and it's really stock.
You can install everything.
If you buy an Edison, you
don't even need to Flash it.
So it's going to work.
And the Dell Gateway
is running Ubuntu.
Now, that's connecting
to our cloud.
Our cloud is purposely
under-powered micro instance
on Amazon EC2 because
what we're trying
to do is really show
connectivity and performance,
and when you're
dealing with billions
and billions of
devices, you really
want to develop on very,
very small platforms.
It's much easier to
use more CPU than less.
So all of our development has
really taken that into account.
So the Android phone that
I have here is actually
connected to this cloud.
The link that I'm
running on my phone
itself, that's also
connected to the cloud.
Now, if I jump back
to this screen,
you'll actually see that it's
actually a little polymer
application right
here that is created
and it's using the HTML5
standard APIs to just pick up
all the [INAUDIBLE] and
all the different data
and send it over to DSA.
So you don't even need to be
running the connectors for DSA
service side.
And that was a very
big goal for us.
Because what we
really wanted to do
is utilize the internet
for all communications.
You don't want to open up
holes in your firewall.
You don't want to create
routes just so you
want to control something.
Because when we're talking
about all these connections,
at the end of the day, even when
I'm entering my Cloud Endpoint,
I still have with
permissions full control
of the devices that are maybe
three, four levels underneath.
And that's really important.
The Intel Edison also
has a little board on it.
So you can see the temperature
that it's outputting as well.
And if I play around a
little bit with lights,
you can see me changing
the light colors.
If I blow on the Edison, you
can see the temperature gauge
changing.
So the robot is
getting a little tired.
Now that we have all of
these things connected,
we can start to build logic.
Now, logic, as I
explained earlier,
is built utilizing
data flow such as this.
So this is a very
simple data flow
that is going to be driving
a game that we're all going
to be playing a little later.
I'd like to show you
another little demo
because once this data starts
flowing and we have our phone
and you see we're
spinning it around,
we can bring up and discover
some interesting novel control
concepts.
So now I can use
my phone as a dial
to change the hue-- as
you can see, brightness--
on this light bulb.
But as soon as I
flip my phone around,
I can start controlling
the other bulb.
So now the phone is
utilized as an analog gauge.
And surprisingly, this is
not something we built.
As soon as we connect
to everything,
and all this data is there
for us and it's flowing.
Because what DGLux
allows us to see--
and if I actually zoom
in a little bit maybe
it's going to make it easier
for everybody to see that--
but you can see all of
this data that's flowing.
So if I bring up our
iPhone DSLink right here,
you can see all of
the sensor readings.
And I can actually show
you how something like that
is created in DGLux.
We can drag out an iPhone
image in edit mode.
Here it is.
DGLux has all the
different tools
for all the graphical
manipulations
that HTML5 allows.
So it supports pretty
much every single HTML5
and it exposes that
for you in a graphical
what you see is what you
get environment, including,
of course, transform.
So you can see the phone--
the HTML5 is outputting
alpha, beta, and gamma.
So I can take these
metrics that are live
and I can bind them directly.
This lets me do some
conversions right on the fly
as I'm spinning
the phone around.
But in this case, I don't
need to do anything.
Notice that it can
even move it around
and it's still reacting to all
the changes that I'm showing.
So this is always
truly what you see
is what you get and always live.
So if I link alpha,
beta, gamma, you
will see how everything
really ties together.
So I'm sure you've
noticed this by now,
but what we're really
trying to do is
we're trying to open data up.
We've created a solution
that is open source--
not just open source with a
commercial license clause,
but it's truly free.
There's no commercial
licenses for DSA.
It's licensed under Apache 2.
And we're trying to
democratize data.
So we are trying to create
an open source platform that
will connect all these devices,
services, and things together
in such a way that, like us that
can build a commercial product
on top of all of this
live, streaming data,
you can also create commercial
or potential open source
products on top
of all this data.
All the code is
available on GitHub.
And you can always go
IOT-DSA.org to see the website
for DSA.
Now, I also want to call out
DGLogik DSA contributors.
You could see them listed here.
These gentleman contributed
pretty much all the source code
that you see right now.
We do have a few external
contributors already,
but this is one thing that I
would really like everybody
to walk away from.
For us to really truly have
of this connected world
of the future
together, we can not
be relying on a
proprietary system that's
going to be taking all our
data and marshaling this.
In a perfect world, the system
is going to be created in Dart
and it'll be DSA.
Now it's time for a game.
So if everybody that's connected
or online can go to this URL,
and I will actually also
put it into Slack as well.
That's set up for
the Dart Summit.
I will show this in one second.
It's in Slack now.
This is the URL--
game.iot-dsa.org.
I'm actually going to bring
it up on my phone as well.
So we can see how many
players are coming on already.
Now, this wasn't
done on purpose,
but everything I just showed
you, including our company
name, starts with a D. You
have DGLogik, DGLux 5, DSA,
and Dart.
So I guess it's a
marriage made in heaven.
So I guess I'll give everybody
maybe 30 more seconds to join.
It's game.iot-dsa.org.
Good.
We're using you guys for a test.
We see-- oh, it's not responding
because the game hasn't
started yet.
So it's not hanging.
We're just waiting for
everybody to log on.
But I think we
have enough people.
So let's turn it on
because as I said,
this whole game,
what we're doing--
and the goal of
this game-- is going
to be tapping the
randomized button color that
was provided to you by
the sweet random number
generator in Dart.
And we're going to see
whose team is going to win.
So you'll notice that
this game is actually
called performance test.
So I'm going to go ahead and
we're going to enable the game.
But wait for me.
I want to play too.
Now it's enabled.
Wow, everybody click,
click, click, click.
My phone is-- there it is.
That's a lot of clicks.
And that's a lot of players.
Come on, help us test our
micro EC2 instance and Dart VM
and Dart 2JS and web sockets.
This is a test for everything.
So while the game is
going on, maybe anybody
has some questions for me?
There's about
three minutes left.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DENNIS KHVOSTIONOV: So DGLux
is our commercial product.
MODERATOR: Could you
repeat the question?
DENNIS KHVOSTIONOV: So is
there anything in DGLux
that's not in DSA.
And what I was going
to say is that DGLux
is our commercial product, so
it's using all the APIs of DSA
to get the data.
And we actually have
sample applications
that are doing exactly the
same thing as DGLux-- it's
written in Dart and
Polymer, and you
can see that I'm GitHub--
that are pulling the data
and visualizing and subscribing
in all the same ways.
But the DSA is really
the underpinnings.
Now, you can see the Philips
Hue is still on a [INAUDIBLE]
already.
Who's winning, by the way.
AUDIENCE: So in theory,
what you could do
is you could have a set
of microphones pulling
in some audio data and then you
could pull that in and actually
use it to control the
color of the hue light.
Certain frequencies
come in, have
the light come at a certain
color, change all that?
DENNIS KHVOSTIONOV: Just
like the winning team
is showing on the Philips Hue.
MODERATOR: We can maybe
squeeze one more question in.
Anyone?
Raise hands.
Get Kevin to give
you his microphone
or I'll give you mine.
Sorry, you guys are too
busy tapping right now.
Here's a question back here.
Kevin will bring you the mic.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that you're just
using standard ports-- port
80, I guess-- on the incoming
to the devices or
anything like that.
What other security
concerns do you
have for malicious
attacks on the devices?
Because if you're just throwing
it out there on port 80
and not doing any other ports
or locking it down in any way
and you're allowing
any traffic inbound,
I could see a potential
for security concerns.
DENNIS KHVOSTIONOV:
So the question
was what type of security
are we implementing?
Because we are
using the internet
as a backbone for all
communications going
to port 80.
So what security
measures are in place?
Well, the answer to
that is it's not just
you connect to port 80.
It's not a REST API.
REST APIs wouldn't really
work in this instance
because we need to have a
device-- everything connects
upstream.
Because you'll notice you're
playing this game on the cloud,
but it's actually controlling
the Philips Hue bulbs that
are connected to
this Intel Edison
through three different hubs.
So there's a handshake
mechanism that happens
and it's the device that
connects to the broker.
You can never connect
to this device directly.
You cannot connect to a DSLink.
So it connects to the broker
and the broker white lists it.
So nothing is going to happen
until that device becomes
white listed.
And we do have
security for handshakes
and other aspects of DSA.
And I personally believe
security by openness and not
by obscurity.
So it's all right there
for you to see in the code
and comment and take a
look at our documentation
and to spot vulnerabilities
and to help us fix them.
And that's what we really
hope is going to happen.
MODERATOR: I think we're
probably good on time.
Thank you so much.
DENNIS KHVOSTIONOV: So who won?
MODERATOR: Who won?
DENNIS KHVOSTIONOV: So
we're going to do a test.
The first person that shows
me their phone gets the robot.
No, I couldn't do it.
But I think you were first.
Here.
Because this robot
had broken, already.
It's already broke.
MODERATOR: Do I need to bring
up the code of conduct again?
Bob, that is legal in
California, actually.
So you can connect to
it using Bluetooth LE,
and this robot has
a mind of its own.
So it's actually broken already
six different Philips Hue
bulbs, so yeah.
OK.
All set.
Thank you very much.